so anyways Pinocchio doesn't know any
better and he's got the egotism of you
know of youth and he's offered the easy
way to success which is exactly what the
Fox tells them and off they go to see
Stromboli so this is the song I'm not
going to read it all it's great to be a
celebrity an actor's life for me you
sleep till after 2:00 you Pramod ate a
big cigar you tour the world in a
private car you dine on chicken and
caviar an actor's life for me so it's
all this idea of wealth and public
exposure and zero attention whatsoever
to anything regarding responsibility or
discipline or learning and so it's a
dual attraction right you get everything
you want and you don't have to do
anything geez what a deal and so that's
what the actor represents it's it's a
liar fundamentally it's someone who's
acting out a deception they're a persona
in the Union sense so the persona is the
mask you wear in public that you might
even think you are but you're not it's
this mask and that's the actor that's
the persona so the Fox and the cat are
inviting that the puppet to only become
a persona and and that's that's see for
young you start as a persona and then
when you start to investigate the parts
of you that don't really fit in that
persona that would be the shadow then
you start understanding who you really
are and that's shocking because the
persona contains everything roughly
speaking that you think is good and
maybe even that your immediate culture
thinks is good and then the shadow
contains everything that's not part of
that and some of that's really bad but
some of it is good disguised as bad and
you can't break out of the persona and
transcend it until you incorporate a lot
of what's in the shadow and so for
example if you're an extraordinarily
compassionate person let's say 98% L
will say you're going to be sacrificing
yourself to other people all the time
and there are people who will find that
extraordinarily endearing and it will be
under some circumstances but the problem
is is that you will sacrifice yourself
and that's a really bad attitude
have for example towards adult males
it's a great thing for infants but for
adult males it is the wrong approach and
so you will get taken advantage of
continually by people who are looking
for someone like you until you grow some
teeth and you'll think no no that's the
opposite of compassion being able to
bite hard is the opposite of compassion
which it is and so you'll have that
pushed into the predator category I'm
not doing that I'm not getting angry I
don't like conflict it's like until you
bring that out of the depths and put it
on so you can use it you're gonna be in
trouble and that's kind of Nietzsche's
idea of the revaluation of good and evil
right you have a sense of what's good in
a sense of what isn't with your
conscience but it's not very smart it's
got things in the wrong boxes and a lot
of the things that even nature itself a
lot of the things that you accept as
untrammeled goods like compassion let's
say have a very dark side first of all
and second are not enough to get you
through life you need the opposite
virtues too and so you have to develop
them and so you get outside the persona
to do that but anyways Pinocchio is
invited to be a false persona to take
the gains of celebrity without having to
do anything to be educated he's just
gonna go right to the top from right
where he is and you know people are kind
of fascinated by that idea that's why
you watch America's Got Talent or the X
Factor which are shows I actually love
by the way you you you never see
narcissism in its pure forms then you
see it when you watch people who display
an absolute lack of talent and become
homicidal when someone dares pointed out
right accusatory and homicidal instantly
it's it's really something and then now
and then you Dee's do see one of these
people who's so introverted and so out
of society and have this unbelievable
gift which is also something really
remarkable to see and it's no wonder
those things are so popular they're
psychologically extraordinarily
interesting